Scarlett Johansson should star in a solo Black
Widow movie.
Considering she made her first appearance
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe before Thor,
Captain America, Ant-Man, and the Guardians
of the Galaxy, it seems like Black Widow is
long overdue for her own top-billed adventure.
Yet despite the fact that fans overwhelmingly
voted in favor of Widow getting her own film
over any other supporting MCU character, and
the fact that Johansson was named the highest-grossing
actress of all time in 2016, Marvel still
hasn’t announced a solo project.
So why won't Marvel give Black Widow a movie?
Best supporting superhero
One of the reasons Black Widow is so popular
is that she's served as an excellent foil
to characters like Iron Man and Captain America
since her first MCU appearance.
That's not to diminish her importance as a
character and hero in her own right.
But if Marvel elevates Black Widow to top-billing
status, it'll be trickier for her to come
back to fill the hugely important supporting
roles she's provided.
Not every character is built for starring
roles.
That's why we still haven't gotten a movie
based on Robin's solo adventures, despite
the fact that he's one of the most recognizable
characters around.
"Holy Shrinkage"
Grounded
Compared with her Avengers colleagues, Black
Widow stands out as underpowered.
Marvel movies showcase characters doing amazing,
unbelievable things, often with the help of
super-soldier serum, gamma rays, sci-fi suits,
or magic hammers.
But Black Widow works best as a ground-level
secret agent.
A Black Widow spy movie would be absolutely
awesome, and could put any Jason Bourne or
James Bond adventure to shame…but it wouldn't
really be a Marvel movie any more than a rom-com
would.
"Hey, I'm Ultron"
"Black Widow"
"You wanna grab a coffee?"
"I don't really have time to date any guys
now"
"What about robots?"
"He He"
Not iconic enough
They say a hero is only as good as his or
her villains.
So, with that in mind, take a moment and think
about your favorite Black Widow villain.
Who'd you pick?
That's right: probably no one.
Unlike the rogues galleries that pester Cap,
Thor, and even Batman and Superman, there
really are no awesome, immediately recognizable
baddies for Black Widow to fight.
While that weakness hasn't stopped other superheroes
from earning their own movies, it could be
another reason Marvel's waited to give her
one.
Toying with fans
Summer blockbusters are often two-hour toy,
bedsheet, and backpack commercials, designed
to sell merchandise to as many kids and collectors
as possible.
So let's recall the controversy from 2015,
when Disney and Marvel's decided to largely
exclude Black Widow from Avengers: Age of
Ultron toy lines.
And in May 2016, news hit that Iron Man 3's
villain was switched from a female to a male
before filming began for one reason: "that
toy won't sell as well if it's a female."
"What you just said is one of the most insanely
idiotic things I have ever heard."
Of course, Disney also faced massive backlash
over this kind of thinking over the company's
decision to under-include Rey in the Star
Wars action figure line, so maybe the company's
finally learned its lesson.
And that might help a Black Widow movie — action
figures and all — finally move forward.
Hope for Black Widow
Since 2007, Marvel Studios President Kevin
Feige answered to eccentric Marvel Entertainment
CEO Isaac "Ike" Perlmutter, who is so reclusive
he reportedly wore a fake mustache at the
2008 Iron Man premiere like he was Bobby Valentine
or something.
Perlmutter was also reportedly behind that
Iron Man 3 villain gender swap decision, among
others.
But in August 2015, a little over five years
after Disney acquired Marvel proper, corporate
reshuffling resulted in Marvel Studios being
directly absorbed by Walt Disney Studios,
freeing Feige from Perlmutter’s control.
Party!
So how does that affect Black Widow fans?
It means that Feige may be able to make good
on his comments from May of 2016, when he
said that he was committed to a solo Black
Widow movie actually happening sometime by
2020.
After Walt Disney Studios absorbed Marvel
Studios, he finally had the power to put those
plans into motion without Perlmutter's interference.
Whether or not Johansson will still be available
and interested to take this movie on is anybody's
guess.
But for now, the possibility is greater than
ever before.
Here's hoping it happens.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know why
you think Black Widow should get a movie…